bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got a
special treat for you today i have jeff
morris here thank you so much for doing
this sir
just waking up and this is the best way
to start the day so i'm excited to be
here
most people don't say that to me so i'll
take it uh but
let's jump into uh let's jump into your
background uh
you're investing today but you spent a
good amount of time as an operator kind
of walk us through where did you grow up
how did you get into
the technology industry and what you do
sure so i grew up
five minutes from palo alto uh and five
minutes from st hill road so it's really
kind of in the heart of technology and
venture
you know went to menlo high school kind
of grew up around the scene
ended up uh going to ucla to study
english
thought i want to be some something in
film
i was screenwriting for a little bit uh
i worked at uta which is an
agency i used to read scripts for 50
bucks in
in college for different producers in la
and really thought that was my track and
then
when i went to the agency world i just
realized how how shitty
uh being in being in the entertainment
is that i literally like
if you'd watch entourage i've had like
staplers thrown at me like
like my life was threatened many times
it just wasn't a healthy environment
and so i left i was going through a
breakup with the girlfriend and just
kind of like left l.a getting classic
kind of road trip style packed the car
uh moved back up to san francisco and
then i was just this was 2010 and
there was so many great companies around
so um and i had i still had good
connections but i wasn't like going to
just get a job i wasn't gonna walk
through
a door and get a job because i knew
anybody um and so i just started
applying every
every company i could apply to and it
turns out i was really good at applying
to unicorns i applied to
uber to be their 15th employee i applied
to airbnb to be their 50th employee
and i applied to twitter to be like
their 200th employee and and
none of them would hire me so i ended up
going to south by southwest in 2011 i
had
just a i was asleep on someone's couch i
had no no
reason to be there but i met a company
called zarly and they were based in
kansas city at the time
in seattle but um i ended up just late
night on twitter i saw the ceo post
a job opening i was the first one to
apply i wrote a really kind of dramatic
uh cover letter and he got on the phone
the next day and said he would
hire me but i had to move the next day
to kansas city and so at that point i
was kind of
just kind of beating it up by trying to
apply all these companies and
so i i said [ __ ] it and i moved to
kansas city and um
that was really my entry point into in
to attack i had to literally move
from la to san francisco to the middle
of nowhere to get a job and then
from there was just kind of became known
for building products
uh towards the end of this early i i
started releasing a bunch of products
online
on mostly on product hunt and i had
three products hit number one within
a couple months and then suddenly um i
was like the product person on twitter
and and
uh tested out a few ideas i thought i
was going to try and be
a ceo so i tried to start a a gas
delivery business which is really a dumb
business to start so don't start it if
you're thinking about it but
we were driving i had a jeep wrangler so
we we would attach
uh uh little oil tanks to the back of my
car we were driving around filling up uh
cars in menlo park i also realize people
like their gas
in the morning and at night so it's not
a great time to be an operator you have
to wake up early
and stay late so i ended up leaving the
gas industry and
luckily at that time i got a phone call
from tinder
and i'd use tinder i was in online data
for
for several years um uh at that time you
wouldn't say that out loud because
online dating was still
kind of a just a weird world and a weird
thing to say you did
and so ended up moving to la i was one
of their early product members
joined in 2015 the team was about 55
people big
really amazing product market fit but a
very disorganized organized organization
we were just starting to to monetize so
we were doing
about 20 million dollars in revenue i
think a lot of people
misunderstood tinder and subscription
businesses and didn't realize what we'd
become but
um you know kind of like right place
right time and also
just hard work but i ended up leading
all the revenue
products at tinder kind of from 20
million to
1.4 billion in in revenue and it's
very much sas revenue because it's 97 of
our revenue subscriptions
um and and from there just
became kind of like twitter twitter
famous which sounds weird to say you
probably understand it pomp but
people were really curious to learn
about tinder and how we were suddenly
becoming a
a monster business and so um i was
sharing a lot of those thoughts and
and and just became kind of like a
person
in the tech world and had since gone on
to do a lot of things and now kind of
focus on investing
yeah let's go back to uh when you put
three products to the top of product
hunt this is when uh
product hunt like everyone was paying
attention and it was the only thing i
think now there's kind of a couple of
competitors and maybe some of the
attention is a little bit fragmented but
what were the products and
kind of why do you think they hit number
one yeah sure so
um i mean i think the the biggest thing
was they were really
like very quick projects that i built
which enabled them to be a lot more
timely
um and so one of the products was
a good example slack was blowing up
everybody was joining these kind of
consumer
slot group so uh slack was really an
enterprise tool they were
they did not want you to discover uh the
fact that they had like aol chat rooms
um and so i released the the kind of the
the biggest one that
that did really well was called slack
chats
and so think of it as just being a
directory of all the best
slack rooms for non-work topics
and it did really well it was getting
a ton of traffic and then i got a letter
from slack asking
me to seize and desist is what you call
it asking me to take it to take it down
um to which i i kind of fought back
because
i was so happy and you know to me i
thought i was doing them a service
um by giving them more more traffic but
um
eventually took that one down and they
sent me the
the the funniest part of the story is
they sent me a pair of slack socks after
i took it down
which was less less than the price of
the domain i was like all right great
now i
have to wear your socks on my feet to
remind myself of this
uh this season this is letter i got but
um
that was one of them and then another
one was uh called startup adoption
agency
and so it was just this idea of
everybody was launching products on
product hunt
and a lot of people would have been in
the projects and you could adopt other
people's
startups which again was like
really easy to do just a little
matchmaking product
and wasn't too too difficult another one
was called request for startups and so
it's taking
uh y combinator every year releases kind
of a
list of startups they're looking to fund
or themes that they're looking to find
and so we would just go to all the bcs
and silicon valley and ask them what
startups they want to fund and
created just a kind of a marketplace of
ideas where we
we try and connect entrepreneurs and
vcs with with projects they actually
want to fund
um but again like these aren't like
there weren't like machine
learning teams they weren't like big
projects they were just things i was
doing on the weekend but
um as you know if you just release a lot
of things whether it's content or
no code projects and then they do well
people start to
to associate you with with being a
certain type of person and for me it was
just being someone who can release
products at a fast rate
um yeah what's so fascinating to me
about this is
uh you basically were practicing like
you were getting reps and you were
creating lots and lots of products and
you were learning along the way
uh what works what doesn't work you know
how to build how to iterate
uh you're getting kind of really tight
feedback loops
i'm assuming that you think that a lot
of that practice
was very helpful when it came to tinder
and some of the stuff you did later
totally yeah i was it was more
frustration because keep in mind i was
also
trying to launch this gas business like
that
which was just an impossible logistical
business to run and i was like
i can't release this because i have to
deal with um literally like
like local regulations and governing
bodies but
i can release this this little cheap
project only on the weekends um
and then when i got to tinder i didn't
have engineers um
all i had we ended up giving me access
to this platform where you could send
push notifications
that was all literally all i could do
for six months was send push
notifications so i started having
a lot of fun with that and i started to
kind of run product tests through
push notifications so i'll give you a
couple examples one was
uh we had this tool where i could draw a
map around
any any location so i would i would
spend my nights like creating little
uh circumferences around around
different venues
being like if coachella was going on i
would send them
what we called a swipe surge
notification that just said
like tinder's blowing up at coachella
like open tinder right now
um and i would do that for all the large
events in in the country
uh so that was one example no engineers
and then
we ran a similar thing on um in dating
the the biggest day kind of like our
black friday
is always the day after new year's
because people
make their their resolutions they're
probably hungover they sit on the couch
and a lot of them want to meet people
and so we did a swipe search on
january 1st it must been like 2016
um globally which is pretty scary to do
because you're sending
40 million push notifications which is
you know if you think about that
just traffic if you put those people in
a football stadium that'd be
like 400 football stadiums um but but
that ended up being our highest traffic
day
ever um and then you know it got it got
a techcrunch article
and then the whole company was like
who's this person on the side like
sending
these cool push notifications that's you
know driving our our
highest traffic days and and then
suddenly like
people sort of take me more seriously at
tinder but i think anytime you
enter a new job or or a product team
specifically you need to
like earn the respect of your teammates
and for me
i didn't have engineers but i had this
little tool that i could
mess around with and um i think i became
like known on the tinder team as someone
who could do good work just because i
was
forcing my way into uh kind of into
uh being a person on the team
yeah what's fascinating to hear is
you're basically talking about various
features
that maybe people don't think of as part
of the product right so people think of
product they think of like the user
experience when somebody's in the
product
or they think of kind of what does this
product solve for me
but as a product leader how do you kind
of holistically think
both about the user experience you're
presenting to somebody kind of the back
end and what the product can do
but then things like push notifications
uh you know
all sorts of prediction algorithms um
just
how do you think about product and what
makes a good product in today's
environment
yeah i think um you always have to start
with one core
product loop that just works like um
for tinder was we tried to innovate on
swiping for
five or six years is actually really
frustrating as a product person because
you were trying to like out do the swipe
but
for us that uh that core mechanic of
just seeing profiles and quickly
saying yes or no was so mindless and and
core to the product that we had a really
great foundation to to build off of
um so you need you need that like
foundation whatever it is like that hook
or that loop that just keeps people
coming back for more
and then you know around that especially
for mobile
uh the the hidden secret amongst product
people and
most people who are in the industry know
this is push notifications are really
your lifeblood
um that's your retention tool that keeps
people coming back because
most people's phones are so crowded with
different applications that if you don't
have
a good way to pull people back in
through push notifications they just
won't
think to open your app um and so a lot
of messaging
the the kind of highest retention apps
are always messaging because
you get the most push notifications
generally um
but you know for for tinder specifically
we our goal was to get you a match as
quickly as possible so we could get you
in that
messaging loop where you were having a
conversation and that became kind of the
driver of retention
um but you know i really think of it as
being you have to have that core product
and then
and then it's all about finding ways to
keep people coming back and
um you know i think that com comes with
pros and cons
um because you can have you can lose
trust with the the user if you're
if you're spammy or you're not
delivering value through those
notifications but
for something like tinder which is
dating like
it people perceive dating as a very high
value activity to their
their lives um and if you if you miss a
push notification you're slow to respond
to someone it might be
that might be your soul mate um and see
maybe maybe you just miss like the
person you're supposed to spend the next
60 years of your life with or maybe it's
just the person that you want to have a
fun weekend with so
um uh you know it's it's it's a pretty
high value activity so we were really
lucky to be in dating
which i think is just a fun place to to
build in
yeah how much of this is like master
strokes of genius where
uh you and the rest of the product team
sit in a room and you say oh we have
this amazing idea like let's just go
implement it and it works
versus it's a much more iterative
process and you're just testing so many
different things and doubling down all
the things that work
it's a combination of both i think every
team
every product team has to have a few
really ambitious projects every year
um where you're kind of taking a leap of
faith and
whether it's through user interviews or
data
or just like something in your gut tells
you this is what you need to build
you need you need those big ambitious
projects and most of those projects
actually don't end up working sadly um
you know i think it's it's why uh
companies do things like a b testing and
you you do try and roll out cheaper
versions so you're not spending
three or four months of engineering time
doing those projects but um
you know around all that is is just a
ton of av
a b test and experimentation um
and a big a big metric of successful
product teams is just your
your testing velocity like how quickly
can you
release tests um how do you build that
muscle internally
uh how do you get to significance in
your tests which for tinder was very
easy because we had such a large
user base if you're a startup it's hard
to run a ton of a b test because you
don't have
users to run those tests with but
you know it's really a muscle you need
to build and for most startups you don't
actually build that for a couple years
like at tinder we weren't
great at a b testing until probably four
or five years into into the company and
i'm sure there's still room to improve
yeah what about user research in terms
of
not a master stroke of genius not
actually like just we're going to throw
things out and test but actually going
and talking to the users
and getting specific ideas or feedback
from them how do you guys think about
that from a product iteration standpoint
at
uh tinder and then how do you think
about it for startups in general
yeah definitely i mean i think um again
like tinder was such a
topical product that you can get your
user research in the back of an uber or
at
a sunday brunch or people if you tell
people you work at tinder
they will just start talking for 30
minutes like you don't even have a
chance to say a word
and they'll tell you all sorts of
stories and
and they'll give you plenty of product
feedback um but we didn't really
formalize the user research until again
like
probably 2018 or so in which um tinder
was
was already four or five years old and
um
you know i think a lot of the feedback
we got
um at certain times was done kind of by
third parties which
it's hard for someone who works in
product and thinks they're
they know what they're doing to kind of
like trust like third-party research and
you know someone does like a big user
study and
they tell you what to build so i think
the most valuable feedback is
um is one-to-one feedback that you get
yourself and
the job of a product manager product
team is to really
consolidate that feedback and and build
the right solutions but
i remember there was a point where
towards the end of tinder i was actually
on i started a kind of experimentation
playing a team is is an exaggeration but
i went off and i was like i want to
build
an entirely new company within tinder
and it was the first time i think in a
couple years where i literally just
i identified our our highest paying
subscribers
um and i just asked them if they would
do a phone call with me and i probably
did 20 phone calls and i was like holy
[ __ ] like these people will talk to us
so
you know we're a a public company and
our users will
still talk to us but it's just a good
lesson that uh people are
willing to talk to you and i think the
more you can just have
one-on-one conversations like we're
having right now with with users
as long as you have the right sample set
um that to me is the best feedback
way better than anything that a third
party could could
give you in a 100 page uh uh
print out of what your users want you to
build
yeah and what about like gamification in
the product one of the things i think
that tinder really did well
was everything from like the super like
all the way on down there were so many
features
that had monetization kind of woven into
them
and made it a better experience but also
made revenue for the business talk a
little bit about just the philosophy
behind kind of gamifying some of the
tinder experience you already knew had
product market fit
yeah so a lot of people refer to tinder
as a game
there was there were moments internally
where we referred it as a game i think
some people think that's off-putting but
the truth is a lot of people want
to use tinder just to have fun a lot of
people don't even plan
to date they just they like the game of
swiping on people and seeing who likes
them
um and so we we definitely leaned into
that i think
a lot of the the products we built were
products that are already been built for
dating which
has a ton of people in gaming move over
to to dating because
it's just a really fun place to build
but um
super like as an example or i think
boost is a really fun one it's
you can use a boost to to get more
impressions on your profile
and it's kind of when you buy it there's
this crazy animation of lightning bolts
flying around the screen and it does
feel like
um if you've ever played nba jam and you
you kind of
your player goes on fire it's or like
mario kart when you when you uh
get the i don't know what the the icon
is you start racing on the track a lot
faster
um and we tried to lean into those
playful moments and we added
crazy video game like animations just to
let the user know like hey
we know this is kind of um ridiculous
that you're buying a boost to
uh to amplify your profile we don't want
this to feel like
google adwords um let's let's have some
fun and i think
the more fat tinder that we just
realized that people want to have fun
with the product
i think a lot of people wanted tinder to
to say it was it was a dating product or
to define its use case and we were just
like the
the word association is just fun um and
we didn't want to be
we didn't want to tell users what to use
tinder for and i think part of that was
the gamification and just leaning
leading into the fact that we knew
um dating is is just kind of a crazy
thing and
um we didn't want to be a serious
product and we never we never
i don't think we ever got there as a
product which is a good thing
yeah before we move on to talk about the
investing uh talk a little bit just
about one or two stories maybe like what
was the biggest product improvement you
made that moved the numbers in a
positive way
and then maybe something you guys tried
that you immediately realized like wait
we might be tanking the numbers and
probably should shut this experiment off
yeah totally so i think um kind of my
defining moment in the
big product i built was tinder gold
which um we had tinder plus which was
kind of our entry level subscription
package and tinder gold
really just moved the business in in
a hugely impactful way and the core
feature in that was being able to see
who likes you before you swipe which
actually was a pretty scary thing to
build because
um we had these these rules of tinder
and one of the rules was
this kind of like double opt-in to
swiping like you don't know who
likes you and they don't know who likes
you when when you're both swiping but
um you know again back to video games
like
we have these rules that we come up with
as product people
and my job on the revenue team was to
break the rules a little bit
for for a subset of users and say hey if
we if we let
10 of our users uh access
this feature that that kind of breaks
the game um
will that will that hey is that
something that they want to pay for and
then two will that literally just like
blow up the ecosystem of tinder and in
the case of of tinder golden scene who
likes you before you swipe
um everything was fine it not only did
increase revenue dramatically it led to
more matches it created more
conversations it got the
that engagement loop i talked about um
was was really sticky and so
but that was just huge and it was really
fun because we were a public company and
so
um you know like nothing gets a teamwork
excited when you're public coming and
seeing your stock price go up it's just
addicting especially in like the robin
hood era where everyone's checking the
stock price and
um you know we can we can pretend that
doesn't exist but
every day everybody when you walk in the
office knows what the stock price is
and everybody gets really excited so
when when tinder gold came out and it
kind of like
it literally like 2x the enterprise
value of tinder
people were just pumped up like like the
mood was always good when we walked in
the office
um and and our team was really proud it
was it was a
again like we your internal
uh kind of like like respect just keeps
going up if you build products like that
and
it was just a really fun product to
build i think um
you know some things that that were hard
to do at tinder
um we always wanted tinder to be and
and a lot of people pushed us in this
direction i think
we wanted to be a social product because
um
you know obviously like like bringing
your friends on a tinder drive's growth
it also
i think in the public markets if you're
classified as a social product
um it's a it has a higher tan than a
dating product and so
we built this product called tinder
social which basically allows you to
swipe with friends
and um it just didn't like
dating at its core is kind of a
one-to-one
activity and um we always try to build
like sharing mechanics and and all these
growth kind of growth hooks but
in some cases people view bringing their
friends onto tinder as being
competitive like if you go to a bar and
you have a bunch of
you bring a bunch of your uh cool
attractive friends
uh maybe that lowers your odds of
finding finding success or finding your
soulmate
um and so so social products were just
really hard to build on dating and
that was something we we saw with to new
social
all depends on if your friends are
attractive or not i guess but yes
that makes a lot of sense i lived with
with water polo players when i went to
ucla and they were
six foot four and way better looking
than me so i i had to be like the
the funny intellectual person on the
side who would occasionally like
meet my soulmate in that way
i love it uh let's talk about investing
uh you're investing at a chapter one
talk a little bit just about your
investing philosophy
why go focus on this full-time um and
kind of how you think about the
companies that you're looking for
yeah sure so while i was at tinder i was
doing
a lot of investing and i had uh launched
a big angelus syndicate i was one of the
larger syndicates just by like backers
on the platform
i was getting the really cool companies
through just being like
a person in tech so i'd invested in
companies like lyft superhuman
cameo and the list kind of goes on but
saw myself getting onto really great cap
tables and
um you know angelus has a product that
lets you
launch a fun within within days and they
set up all your back office legal
compliance
and so i decided just to run an
experiment again i wasn't thinking too
deeply about it
i just emailed my my backers on ageless
and said hey i'm starting a bond
um who wants to to invest in me and i
think i had a million dollars of
commitments within
a day and i was like holy [ __ ] now i
managed i'm managing the fun
um and so then i i made a deck and i got
more serious about it
and ended up raising
about a 10 million dollar fund over the
course of of six months but
um was doing this at nights and on the
weekends and and really
there was a breaking point where i i
felt like i was doing both
um product and investing i was probably
like
giving myself i would give myself like a
c plus because i was just so
uh distracted in both directions and so
i needed to make a choice and for me at
that point i had so much momentum with
with investing that it just made sense
to do it full time i also
got to the point where i i had a little
bit of add out i just enjoy working on
different problems during the day and
investing is
the perfect job if you have any any add
um and so so yeah and then launching
chapter one i think
launching new funds so tough it's so
noisy right now and
you need to figure out what your your
hook is again like it's like a product
um
you need to to have something that just
like stands out in the marketplace
and for me i knew i loved working on
product i knew i loved
uh collaborating with with founders that
way and i also kept
i kept asking founders in kind of those
early investments like why
this was after we we were we started
working i was like why did you like let
me invest
and they kept saying like i wanted um i
wanted your help on product and so i was
like okay like i've heard that
again like user research i've heard that
enough times where i think that's why
people want to work with me
and so i branded the entire fund around
being like the product person on your
cap table
um and so i tell founders like
i want to be your first phone call if
you have any any product
questions whether it's you're having
like some
issue with your a b testing platform or
you're having like this big existential
question around what you want to build
and you just need like a third party to
come in and play tie breaker a little
bit um and and
and then i thought to myself where do
people really need help with product
it's before they have product market fit
and so it made sense to be an earlier
stage investor and so we do precedence
investments um and typically kind of
look for teams that have
a really unique lens on on on
product and normally comes from being
like a former vp of product or director
of product somewhere
or just a great engineer who has product
sensibilities
so i end up working with like a lot of
really uh like nerdy
semi-artistic uh product people who just
like
love to to talk about this stuff all day
long
talk a little bit about your thoughts
like you focus so much on product
i've had people come on the podcast who
say maybe that product doesn't matter
but like distribution is everything
and you know the truth is probably
somewhere in between like you need a
good product and you need good
distribution
how do you kind of think of that at the
earliest stages especially you know
pre-seed and into the seed round
uh for companies especially the ones
that you're working with that are very
product focused
yeah i i've talked with so many people
about this topic and
i you know like the the prideful product
person he says like
product is everything um it's all that
matters but
as you mentioned i think distribution
especially right now is
is probably more important and and that
might go against what
uh kind of the fun thesis is but the
truth is
um you know within your product like
growth and go to market are part of the
product strategy and so it's not
they're not two different um competing
areas
you know if you're building a consumer
mobile product you will get the question
of how
like how are you going to get people to
download your product there's
millions and millions of apps on the app
store and people just don't like
downloading new apps um so that's that's
a big question on the
on the b2b side i think there's um
there's different unlocks whether it's
hey you know we
we have you know we just got through yc
and uh
we have access to 3 000 yc companies
um that's a growth kind of a growth
unlock there's
a bit i'm always looking for different
unfair advantages or
um especially right now like i just did
a consumer deal and we're just stacking
the cap table with
uh tick tock influencers which sounds
funny and i tweeted about this yesterday
but
um i was like which tick tock
influencers are actually investing
right now um and so
we made the choice to not have too many
silicon valley investors we we want
people who have audiences and so um
again and that's all distribution we
know we have a product that works but
we need eyeballs on that product and so
we're trying to figure out how to get
those eyeballs
yeah it's really interesting um as you
think through
uh kind of building in the earliest
stages
is it something that a precede a seed
company again master stroke of genius
just because they don't have enough
traffic to really kind of run an
iterative process and kind of get
feedback
or do you think that many of these
product folks can still
kind of run that iterative process and
maybe they don't have tons of traffic
uh but they can do some things to kind
of short-circuit learnings and and
really get the product in a place where
it's
valuable and finds product market fit
yeah
um i mean most
in consumer especially you need a little
bit of genius you just do like you need
a core
nugget or idea that just blows people's
minds and gets people
to talk about your app enough where it
becomes like a
sunday brunch conversation i i just
believe in consumer that
you need that um that said there's ways
you can run
tests if you don't have traffic and we
see a lot of people do this at
different accelerators or studios more
when they're incubating ideas
is you can take out 15 or 20 000 and run
a bunch of smoke tests against different
landing pages and product ideas
to see what converts and see what people
will literally just sign up for
sometimes you can a b test products with
medium posts like all
sometimes i'll have an id and i'll say
hey i'm building this and i'd launch a
medium post and if nobody
responds then maybe nobody thinks that's
a good idea and
if they do then the only problem is then
you have to to actually build a product
if you say you're going to build them
people want it um but you can you can
you can find ways to to get traffic i
think
you're just trying to see if people will
literally
sign up for it and if you have something
um
you know hopefully hopefully you can
have enough traffic to measure
retention over a period of 28 days or so
um but yeah i i i do think
it's harder to be tested to start up but
don't be creative and figure out ways to
to get that traffic because you can you
can do it if you have a little budget
yeah you're investing as a solo
capitalist
talk through kind of the thought process
of uh
why invest as a solo capitalist what are
the advantages maybe what some of the
disadvantages are as you've been doing
it for a while now
yeah i uh we were talking about this
before the show but um
i've always invested on my on my own and
uh i've just developed a lot of
confidence in
my picking ability um and so i went
through the process
this year of like asking myself do do i
need to bring on other
investors or other gps and um
just in the past year lp's limited
partners have become
so accepting of solo capitalists where
um
to me it's an advantage right now
because you
it's so competitive and if you can move
with with a slightly faster
speed um by being so low you can win
deals and i let a
seed deal this week where i was
literally
i got to them first and i said yes
before they could talk to other
investors and if i had a team
i would need to pull in someone else and
it would be this whole process
i think the key is is building a support
system around you
either through platforms like angelus or
by setting up your own back office where
you don't have to worry about the other
parts of your job and so you can
just focus entirely on investing i also
think a lot of people
as you you have a big kind of online
presence if you have a big
online presence and you can raise money
bring on a partner
in most cases just doesn't really make
sense if you can
if you can you know raise a fund and get
going up
unless you find the perfect compliment
to you and i've gone through the process
of talking to a few folks about
partnering
and it just hasn't uh you know back to
like dating like i haven't found my
perfect match but maybe
maybe one day somebody will come into my
life and i'm
i just need to work with them um but
until that happens i'm so happy doing
what i'm doing now
yeah how do you think about the balance
between like
speed of decision making and quality of
decision making this is something i
constantly go back and forth on right
because
when you're a solo capitalist you
definitely have speed uh but you don't
have those investment committee meetings
you don't have
partners that you can kind of bounce
ideas off of how do you you know are
there things that you maybe you do to to
get
feedback or have sounding boards and
then also how do you just think about
the trade-off between speed and quality
of decisions
yeah sure um so i think there's two
parts of this one is just this idea of a
prepared mind and so it's doing the work
before you have that meeting or knowing
what you're looking for and having seen
enough kind of like like different
versions in my of an idea you've gone
through the idea maze
and when you see it you just know like
you you're like
i've seen 10 of these companies and and
there's a slightly different twist
where this is actually the the company
the back so
having a prepared mind is a big part of
it um
the second part is building kind of
building your your support
uh system in terms of peers and people
you invest with so
um i invest really often with with the
same people
i know we're on cap tables together but
i invest with guys like
uh ryan hoover um uh great investors
like
lee jin um harry stebbings
uh tottenham rule from superhuman so
we're always doing
deals together josh buckley's another
one um
and and and so all i'll send deals to
those people
maybe i'll kind of like be around the
hoop and and thinking about committing
and i just get their reaction so it's
like having an investment committee but
we all have different
balance sheets and different funds um
and so you get you get that peer
feedback but i think i think being a
being an investor can be a really lonely
job as
as you probably know and so you need to
figure out who your
peers are going to be in a lot of people
build peer groups within
investing um they try and go really wide
like they have
a hundred people who they catch up with
every
every couple months and it's it's not
very it's not a very intimate
relationship but i've kind of just like
picked
and it's happened naturally like 10
people who we just
love to to [ __ ] all day long about
investing in
um and we challenge each other and it's
probably what it feels like to have
an investment committee yeah how do you
think about
uh follow-on investments in terms of uh
you're investing at the pre-season seed
do you try to save a bunch of capital
and kind of invest in the stack
do you just say hey look i'm going to
make a good decision pre-seed seed and
then i'll just take the dilution
later on what's the strategy or thought
process
yeah for me um i i have reserves baked
into my
my fund a lot of people view these
smaller funds as being first check funds
and then
you kind of spin up spvs for your
winners
um i talked to a lot of people who are
smarter than me uh mike maples from
floodgate chrystics and from andreessen
horowitz
and they all insisted and they showed me
data
that that suggested having reserves um
would increase my performance as long as
i could pick the right
companies to double down on which is an
entirely different ability
so i have 50 reserves i'll occasionally
do
um i'll i'll see a great series a
occasionally i i didn't invest in the
seed and if i do those i call my
reserves like flexible reserves
so i'll take money out of my reserve
bucket and do the deal even though i
didn't invest in the pre-cedar seed
but out of my fund i think we've
invested in 45 companies i'm looking to
to deploy reserves into like eight my
top eight companies
um and i don't know the hard part about
investing is i know i'm a pretty good
first check picker but
tbd on if i'm the right if i'm good at
reserves and reserves management
and and so i'll be curious to see how it
plays out
are there anything other than just pure
returns that you're looking at to see
how you'll measure whether you're a good
kind of reserve picker or not uh
for me again i worked on revenue teams
like i'm very
dollar driven and so there's no
there's no uh kind of like like
i'm going for for for returns and and
there's
uh i don't get kudos for anything else
so um
i want to to 5x my fund or
you know there's some scenario where my
fun does really well
and becomes kind of a legendary fun and
i i want to be
those stories where people say you know
chris sacca's first fun was like this
because he had uber like everybody wants
to have that legendary fund so
um that's all i care about and and
that's how you stay in the business if
you can't
return capital to investors i'll be out
of this game i'll be back on product
teams
after fun too so um so i'm really you
know
i'm really kind of returns driven it's
hard because you meet great
entrepreneurs and
maybe your check size isn't big enough
that they give you or maybe you love
them but you just don't see the
the kind of market potential what
they're doing and you have to say
no all day long which is the hardest
part about this job
and so yeah that's that's kind of how i
think about the world
makes sense uh what are the some of the
downsides to the solo capitalist model
we talked a little bit maybe just about
kind of being out on an island is there
anything else that
you've noticed is a downside yeah i
think um
i think sometimes you can be viewed in
the market um
or as entrepreneurs as being kind of
like an angel size
check so if you if you start raising a
larger fund maybe you raise you know 40
million dollar fund or even i've seen
silicon plus raise 100 million dollar
funds and you're asking for
a one million dollar check um and then
they have this other fund that has
a platform and they have up like a
platform team and they have
you know 10 partners and it's just it's
like you can imagine how that model
um to some entrepreneurs it appears to
be a better place to go and
it's just different people view view
solar capitalists as being
you're either viewed as a founder you're
viewed as an angel and so
those are hard conversations because i
think that right now again like
if there's a great company there's going
to be dozens of investors trying to get
on the cap table
why are you the person who deserves a
you know a 500k
check or a 250k check which once you
start going above 250k it starts to
become
um hard at the precedence you have to
convince them that you're
either the second or third largest check
and so
and then maybe you make some some
compromises on quality
um at that point and so it's it's this
kind of kind of mouse game of knowing
how big your fun should be based on how
much power you think you have in the
market
and how you're viewed as entrepreneurs
reviewed by customers
how has your process changed with the
pandemic
and kind of the lockdowns are were you
already doing most
everything remote and not a big change
were you taking a lot of in-person
meetings and you had to kind of adjust
yeah it's been uh all all zoom i've i've
invested in
i think 40 plus companies this year and
i've met one of the entrepreneurs
in person and it was after i'd invested
in them
um and so and that's shocking to some
people
like i i i was pitching a really well
known institutional lp and
they asked me the same question i said i
haven't met any of these founders in
person
and i i could kind of tell like based on
their reaction i was like that wasn't
the right answer
uh but this is the new world we live in
and
um especially at the precinct seed it's
so fast people are building products
all around the world now and so and
we're in a pandemic so there's really no
other option you have to figure out how
to evaluate people on on video and a lot
of its
social cues a lot of its reference
checks but
um i've just become so comfortable
interacting
on video and to me i don't need to like
shake someone's hand and
have coffee with them anymore of course
i'd love to i love
i love meeting people in person but if
you do that you'll probably miss the
deal
yeah i i tend to agree uh you recently
posted on twitter
a a photo uh it was very beautifully
taken i don't know who took it but it
was you with the
golden gate bridge behind you and uh the
waves of
of san francisco uh and uh
you i'm gonna paraphrase but basically
look there's a lot of debate right now
on you know every other city in the
world but like san francisco is still
beautiful
uh i took that to be uh you will still
spend a lot of time
in uh in san francisco what's your
general
kind of take on uh austin miami la
san francisco new york and uh you know
wherever else internationally people are
considering yes i post that photo
yesterday and my wife sent
me and i looked at i was like you know
we had a lot of good times in san
francisco i
started my career there i was born in
the bay area i met my wife in san
francisco and so the
twitter narrative is so bearish on san
francisco and it's
you know it's gotten really aggressively
anti-san francisco and
at times i've been a part of that in
different ways um
not aggressively but i've been you know
very open about the fact that i think
san francisco needs to to change
in different ways um i got a text
actually from my mom
two weeks ago kind of uh it was like a
mom to send moment which you still have
when you're when you're adult
uh when you're an adult and she said
like why you know it's kind of like why
are you
um speaking so negatively about san
francisco which i didn't think it was
that negative but
um she was like this is the place where
you grew up and it afforded you so many
great
opportunities and it was just a good
reminder that the city itself and
the barriers given me so much and i was
just trying to like
create some positivity around san
francisco because a lot of my friends
still live there a lot of my family
lives there and
um to wake up and see people
shooting on your city all day long
probably doesn't feel good uh and
in kindly we might move back to san
francisco at some point uh because
again i grew up there and i still think
there's so much value in being
up in the center of it all i've i have a
couple brothers i have a large family
one of them just moved to austin uh in
august
another one's moving to miami in march
and so
i'm i'm like the brother who's trying to
figure out where i belong
and for the moment i'm in la but i think
as you've seen you can build a company
anywhere i think
the question is just can you raise
capital in these places and i
more and more think that investors don't
care where you are as long as you're
building a great company
um and so it's very the one great thing
about the pandemic
is i think people have have finally just
they're like they're like chasing their
like innate desires you're
um it's kind of like this like fantasy
world where it's like where would you
live if you could actually live anywhere
again this is for people who are lucky
enough to be able to do that but
um and you're seeing people live in
hawaii
you've seen people live all over the
place and um you know it's a very
privileged
thing to be able to do but but i'm
seeing people who are you know they're
happier because they're not bound to
one city and it's the quality of life
for them has
has increased in many ways um
so it'll be interesting to see how
things shake out i still think
there will be some pullback on the on
the center
narrative people will come back to san
francisco um i just don't know if it's
going to be quite the center of gravity
that
that it used to be and so i think there
will be especially if the
city doesn't change in terms of um you
know i'm sure you've seen the
debates about chess and the district
attorney and all the
crime it's not a safe place to live
right now and so um
until it becomes a safe place i don't
think it will ever return to being
the san francisco we know and love
absolutely before we move on to anything
else where can people
find you or or send you deals if they're
working on a company that uh they think
could be a good
fit yeah definitely uh so i'm jmj on
twitter which is a great place to find
me and then
um you know my dms are open although
twitter's dm product sucks
um but my dms are open and then
you know there's a chapterone.com is my
website so you can visit chapterone.com
got it the twitter uh dm search works
like
20 of the time 80 percent of the time it
doesn't but at least they have it now so
like i guess that's like somewhat of an
improvement
i know if you want to go viral on
twitter just complain about twitter dms
because everybody will like your posts
and reshare it
it's like it's like the one thing we can
all agree on it's just not
a functional product
before we get into the rapid fire
questions that i always ask everybody i
pulled some questions from twitter
uh and we'll kind of go through these uh
drew morris who i'm assuming has
zero uh relationship to you wants to
know
who is your favorite brother oh man
he's my miami miami brother but i grew
up
in a house with eight kids my parents um
split but they remarried and so there's
kids everywhere
and uh true drew's a lawyer
he likes to ask really pointed questions
so uh
uh honestly i this is gonna be like the
most pc answer but
i love each brother for different things
like drew and i have completely
different conversations we talk about
uh all sorts of stuff and then my
brother in austin loves investing matt
and so i'll call him and we'll just like
talk about the craziest investing ideas
i know pomp you you have brothers but
i have such different relationships with
all my siblings and uh
yeah i can't i can't pick one for you
know that
he knows but he's gonna ask anyways
liz keating asked uh for you to explain
your college bedroom
sun room and explain the impact that it
had on your life
yeah sure so i lived um as you mentioned
with a bunch of water pillow
players and then liz liz was a swimmer
at ucla and is a great friend of mine
she was also in the house but we moved
in together and uh
there was this sunroom in the back and
everybody was picking their bedrooms and
i ran and i was like this is my room i
get the sunroom which i don't think
anybody wanted but i was trying to be
at that time i thought i was going to
become an author and so i was like
this is very like poetic place where i
had a typewriter in there and i was just
like
totally just like in this like fantasy
world i didn't i was
i was an english major um and so the
sunroom just became like a part of my
personality it was like jeff
just the one in the sunroom it was kind
of just like a a weird first choice but
um at the time i was always just trying
to do like
the most hipster emo thing i could do
and it felt like living in the sun room
was like
a place to be an author that's a great
answer
it makes a lot of sense uh
dallas cohen asked uh if you could have
lunch with anyone who is living
who would you choose yeah definitely um
so my grandpa's 100 years old his name
is murph morris he started
mervyn's department stores which ended
up becoming a
large public company and i love talking
to my grandpa
it's just like we can talk about
business i can talk to him about how he
was
you know started his first story he
didn't have any money he took out
a bunch of debt and how he grew that to
becoming just
a public company it's so fun and then
just on a personal level it's pretty
amazing to have
a grandparent that's seen that much um
who's you know been through multiple
wars he's
he was born on the 4th of july so he's
very uh
he's he's he's very patriotic he's just
somebody who i'd love to spend time with
and so
he uh he definitely wins that that
question
that's a fantastic answer uh jonathan
badin i think is how you pronounce it
yeah he wants to know what your morning
routine is which tells me he knows
something i don't know
so what what uh what's he asking for so
badeen
uh is the inventor of the right swipe
which
uh is his his great claim to fame well
deserved but
uh so when i joined tinder i was asked
to there's this website called my
morningroutine.com
and they asked me to write an article if
you read the newsletters it's people who
have these really like prescriptive
morning routines
and so i thought i had at the time i was
pretty regimented in my mornings but i
wrote this ridiculous
uh summary of what i do in the mornings
or what i did and it was like
you know six o'clock i wake up for yoga
like seven o'clock i walk home
i i like you know listen to my record
player for ten minutes or
it was just it was ridiculous and
looking back on it i'm
i blocked myself but it was trying to
like
summarize my morning routine and the
truth is now my morning routine is
completely bonkers like
during during quarantine i'm just like
you can get an extra hour of sleep if
you need it
so um i've just decided that i'm not
gonna pretend to be like
the tim ferriss of morning routines and
i'm i wake up when
when uh when i'm ready and i i work a
long day but i'm not gonna try and be
like
the most productive human in the world
and i don't i don't think that's my
personality at this point
in in life i love that
and i love that he knows that you've got
a great answer to this that's why he's
asking
uh the last one comes from a student
anonymous account uh
stock market hats but it was uh but it
was a good question
uh what is your best and worst
investment that you've made
yeah honestly a lot of my best
investments and i know you're
keeping crypto than crypto bets so um
compound finance was was a really great
one
of course bitcoin's been a great one for
so many
of your listeners but um i love i love
the
the quick returns on on crypto and how
you get liquidity really quickly it's
it's a really attractive thing i think a
lot of my best
investments will still play out on the
private side because i
really started investing five years ago
and so um i invested in a company called
rome research
in march that i'm really excited about
um
and so we'll we'll see what happens but
uh in terms of bad
bets i think i've made a ton of them and
it's mostly things that you
didn't invest in but um
rather than calling out one company i
think it's it's been when
i just invest in things outside of my
strike zone
i've talked with with mike maples a lot
about this it's just like
as an investor you have to know what
you're good at i think it's
this is true for a lot of parts of life
but self-awareness is a big part of
investing
and whenever i've made mistakes it's
just things that i don't know
enough about and so um
part of becoming a good investor is
refining
your idea of what your strike zone is
and then
sticking to it yeah i couldn't agree
more with that
uh i asked the same three questions to
everyone before we wrap up and you'll
get to ask me one to finish
uh the first question is a little bit
more serious what's the most important
book that you've ever read
yeah for me it's it's always catching
the rise is my favorite book i love
holding coffee is this outsider he uh
has his own mind it's also the book
where in high school i read it
and i was i wanted to write like that i
was like i want this like stream of
consciousness
first person narrative and i started to
write a lot after that book and i became
one of my teachers in high school pulled
me at settings like i think you could be
a
a professional writer and so um
and i tried to be a professional writer
i spent two years trying to be a
screenwriter
um and so so that that book really like
led me down this path of
um trying to to communicate better
through through writing yeah it's
awesome that
uh you get inspiration from the things
you consume right
so yeah that's fantastic uh next
question
is from our friends over at eight sleep
they've got me asking everyone
what is your sleep routine and the
context here is i did not sleep at all
like i literally would operate on like
four or five hours i was flying all over
the place and just beating up my body
and uh in 2020 i told myself i'm not
gonna fly anywhere like i'm gonna chill
yeah
and then the world conspired to make
sure that that came true
because literally i was locked in my
apartment um
and uh and i eventually got an eight
sleep mattress and it's like thermo
regulation and i sleep like a baby so
are you somebody who sleeps a lot
who didn't sleep at all how's that
evolved over time
yeah so i actually um uh developed sleep
apnea and
in high school when i was 15 i was i
could not fall asleep for the life of me
and i started taking
tomo pm um eventually i started taking
ambien like it was it was a
it was not good and then um i started to
work out a lot more
and just that helped a lot so i was
working out
um i'd fall asleep better and then um
you know all the way up to now i do have
an eighth sleep mattress so
uh mateo will be happy that uh i got the
aid
the the foam uh pad or the pad that goes
on top of your mattress
and that's been just so cool uh
so my wife has her side of the bed which
she can regulate the temperature and
then i have my side and then
there's no uh i sound like an
advertisement there's no
uh alarm clock because you it vibrates
your side of the bed and so my wife
doesn't have to wake up and be mad at me
when
uh when the alarm goes off in the
morning but that's that's helped a ton
and then
you know i tried again like i try to not
look at devices before bed and
i'm not i'm not a saint like i do i do
check my email before bed and i'm
i'm addicted to work so um but similar
to you i i've started value
my sleep a lot more and i used to sleep
four or five hours a week i was
like cranking you know trying to stay up
until 2 a.m and
i've just gotten to the point where i
thought thought more and more of
like entrepreneurs and and just
investors as being more like athletes
like you have to take care of your mind
and your body to make good decisions
and so i try and get seven or eight
hours of sleep i still have like really
shitty
sleep nights but um but i think i think
socially
the value of sleep has just become such
a topic and
um it's something i'm paying attention
to yeah
i told mateo that this was going to
happen i said if i start asking people
this like
half the guests are going to be your
customers so it's not going to just be
let's talk about hate sleep the last
question i have is more fun
and you get to ask me one uh aliens are
you a believer or a non-believer
i'm a believer i when it comes to space
i trust israel and if they say there's
aliens i'll i'll just go ahead and say
that there's aliens
so you're a what do they say galactic
federation was the guy he said uh
we're all part of a galactic federation
and uh and they just don't want to tell
us yet
i did think so there was one part of
like someone was trying to make trump
unlock all the all the documentation
about uh
aliens before we left left the white
house and of course
today we have a new president and we
didn't see those documents so
uh i'm curious if biden will will unlock
the documents
yeah my favorite moment over the last
four years was i remember when everyone
was gonna storm area 51
and like six people showed up or
something like there's this whole thing
we're just gonna go find it and if
you're like i don't think that's where
they're keeping the information like i'm
pretty sure the information is somewhere
else
yeah i think elon musk should just own
this topic and like
he should be the one that tells the
world if there are aliens or not i think
he
it would just be like the most viral
topic with the most viral person
um it would just light the world on fire
that's a great suggestion don't let him
hear that because he will uh he will
definitely try to
try to do it all right you can ask me
one question to finish up what do you
got for me
yeah pump i'm curious um obviously we
met
i think in 2014 or 2015 and
um you were exploring crypto
and you just made this decision to just
go all in
which for me i think is there's a deeper
part of that which
um is really applicable to to many
people which is just like
owning something and not giving a [ __ ]
if people judge you i'm sure there were
people
in your life who told you you were
insane um i'm sure there were other
investors who told you
you were an idiot and i'm sure there are
a lot of people in silicon valley who
who wrote you off but um what like freed
you
to just jump in and how did you
not give a [ __ ] i guess is the question
yeah
um so i don't think it necessarily was
around like investing
as much you know like hey caring what
other people thought or or not
um i had this really unique experience
when i was 21 years old where
uh i was in the military went to iraq
and
uh i was there with a bunch of guys that
were a little bit older than me
so kind of late 20s early 30s i was
frankly just a dumb naive like very
impressionable kid
and when i got there i had basically
been pulled out of college to go
and so i've been worried about like what
was like the party on friday night right
i mean the same things that everyone's
worried about you know
like do you have enough money to get
some beer and have a good time
and so these guys were worried about
like their wives and their kids and
their mortgage and
is their job gonna take them back when
they come home in like
real life kind of adult things and so
that was like
one like this like maturation process
that like i had to really accelerate
because of um kind of just being around
them in the conversation
but the second thing was like it's war
and so you see
both the good and bad sides of that
situation and
i think that at that age like in that
moment what really stuck to me is just
like
oh we're all gonna die like there's an
end to this thing
uh and so when i came back um
there was a short period of time where i
probably like i
implemented that learning in like a
negative way like i had a motorcycle i'd
go like 120 miles an hour down the
highway and just like
well if it happens when i'm 21 or if it
happens when i'm 81 like
you know it's like very quickly like you
kind of get that out of your system but
i think that it really just got me to
the point where
um i really just didn't care right it
was like hey look
you only have so much time and like who
cares what anybody else thinks and so
like that's a hard lesson to learn
because you have to go through that
specific experience to get that um but i
really carried that with me for
you know ever since really and so when
it came to investing
i think the one thing that um i just
kept telling myself
was like the thing that seems least
likely uh but has the most asymmetry
is like the area to go focus on um and
to me like when i first started looking
at i was like this is insane
like literally like you people are crazy
there is
no way that this is gonna work and i
remember i sat down with a couple of
people and they were like
but if it does and i was like good
yeah like if it does like this is you
know one of the largest
probably like disruptions and not you
know just a bitcoin thing but like from
an ethos standpoint from a
decentralization of privacy-centric
technologies like all this stuff
and so i just slowly started to do it so
it was never like i sat down and was
like you know
all right i'm going to just go focus on
this it was kind of a slow
evolution and then what i started to
realize was as i
got better educated about i started
meeting more people i was like oh like
this is real
right and i felt like i kind of knew
something before other people
um and other people would warm up and
kind of learn it as they spent more and
more time as well um
so that was like one advantage and then
the second thing
was uh i was willing to be wrong and i
think that's where it was one thing to
like have the opinion like hey this is
going to be big and let me like go
invest capital
but a lot of investors like they'll
invest a lot of crazy stuff they don't
talk about it
right or they don't want to like go bang
the drum publicly and like
you know talk about a lot of their early
stage companies until they know it's
going to work and then it's like oh yeah
i was early
right and so for me it was just like
if this works this is going to be really
really disruptive
and i'm willing to like one be wrong in
public but also too i'm willing to learn
in public it's like i'm gonna change my
mind i'm gonna like do all this
and i think it was just the expectation
setting of like i may be wrong but i'm
gonna like go through this entire
journey in public
uh that gave me the like safety net
of if it doesn't work then i'm like well
we all learned together didn't work
so it almost felt lower risk than i
think a lot of people
thought it was um but yeah looking back
like yeah i was pretty crazy
uh i guess and so you know
it's working i guess and that's a good
thing but i still worry that
you know the more and more that uh your
public reputation becomes tied to
something or is like very much
intersected
uh that's great today when it's working
but like god forbid something negative
happens in the future like
there's still risk to some degree and so
you just i think got to be smart about
um you know educating people about hey
here's the risk do your own research
like that's why i talk about that stuff
a lot it's just to
clear my conscience of like hey you know
i'm doing the work i'm making my own
decisions you should do the same thing
and if you do that and you decide
this is what you want to do then uh you
know all for it but uh just make sure
you kind of do your own work
i love that i love the part about you
found something like there's a hidden
secret that you found before
other people and in investing i think
that's so
that's what you're looking for you're
looking for hidden secrets that
whether it's emerging communities or
behaviors and you just know before
everyone else and you
you know for you personally you you did
put yourself out there
as an observer as an observer like and
it was
it was very i think it's very risky to
do that in ways because
at that time maybe maybe you eliminate
yourself from getting a
a gp job at a big venture firm but you
were okay
with with just going in a different
direction with your life and
um you know as an observer it's it's
it's been really fascinating to see
as you know uh when i really started to
learn about it
i thought i missed it right i was like
oh my god like how did i not see
this uh so that was like one weird thing
and then two
i won't say who it is um because i'm
still you know pretty friendly with them
and they've been incredibly gracious
with their time but like
there's two or three people that i
always keep in the back of my head like
i got the messages of like
your torpedoing your career like what
are you doing
um and for whatever reason it's just
like i just followed my gut
and like that's a horrible uh kind of
theoretical
decision-making framework of like i just
felt my gut
but over time i think people just become
more comfortable especially more mature
and kind of more experienced
you just become more comfortable doing
that you can't explain it
um but you know worked out so far so
we'll see
i love it yeah my best decisions are
always when i follow my gut
in investing and in life but investing
and then my worst decisions are when you
have that feeling and you still say yes
um and so that's so powerful and
and again like knowing knowing when to
follow your gut
is is something i've learned it took me
36 years to learn how to do that and i
think i'm still
learning it i have a friend i'll leave
you with this one thing
um he used to always say uh we're doing
irrational things why are you trying to
be rational
right like kind of just you know stop
trying to explain it's not trying to
defend it it's just like
if you believe in it do it so um all
right jeff listen where
uh where can we send people at jmj
on gmj on twitter you can follow me
i tweet a bunch of crazy things um don't
take anything i say too seriously but uh
jmj on twitter and chapterone.com
exactly awesome man all right well
listen thank you so much for doing this
we'll definitely have to do it again in
the future
thanks bob appreciate it